Jalen hurts has the ultimate season
motivator plastered right on the front
of his phone this IG story was posted at
Eagles training camp and if you zoom in
you can see Hertz holding his phone and
if you keep zooming in you can see that
his lock screen is a picture of him
walking out of a confetti-filled stadium
after losing the Super Bowl to the
Chiefs so every time he looks at his
phone he's reminded that he was this
close to his first ring this isn't the
first time that Hertz has done something
like this in 2017 when Alabama lost to
Clemson in the national championship he
saved a photo of Clemson holding the
trophy as his lock screen he said every
time he unlocks it it's a reminder and
it humbles him